good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Monday hey
Claude hyd hey guys happy Monday hey Jax
how you doing I'm doing good you wanna
hear something so weird
sure is it weirder than the fact that
you slammed me for how you turn and now
you just pick it up like it's nothing
I feel like hyt is something that feels
good to say but not good to hear so I
understand why like you want to say it
but you know what like if you were
saying something I just make you feel so
good and special and like heard and you
were enjoying yourself like I just don't
see a scenario in which I would rain on
your parade um so I made the decision a
few days ago a very bad decision to
sleep in a pair of biker shorts okay and
I have literal bruises like the the
tight elastic like on the bottom around
my thigh has left like two circular
spherical bruises where like now I'm
sitting and I feel pain is that weird
yeah it's weird but I think it sort of
makes sense cuz I feel like someone who
would stop their sister from saying
hyoeun is just someone who might fell
asleep in micro shorts and therefore has
have pain well what had happened was I
was so turnt up from our gni that I kind
of just like fell asleep and in like
random [ __ ] that I wouldn't have
normally fallen asleep in but um Jackie
Margot and I had a GN I girls night in
on Friday and we recorded a fabulous
patreon video that you're gonna be able
to watch we did it's taken me all
weekend to get it done because I was so
hungover from gni on Saturday yesterday
I made the video but then my computer
first I did do it again
it's ready to go it'll be up by the time
this episode goes up so definitely enjoy
it we made a flatbread we're drinking
we're chillin um it's good times I think
a lot of people are out of quarantine um
so I don't know if you can remember late
- what we're going through but um
no I'm honestly like this video needs a
trigger warning because it'll remind you
of what quarantine was yeah like trying
to make fetch happen that should be the
title of the video yeah but we actually
really did have a nice time we had such
a fun night
and I was so hungover on Saturday no it
ended up being fabulous but like we were
you know quarantined we were we
definitely definitely were so that'll be
up today that'll be fun um new week new
I new new week famous really ya know
nothing's different I'm just like a
little puffier um I got a few more
pimples I got a hairy amorous stache and
that's that on that but we have now
entered the two-week countdown to my
special June 30th disgraced Queen my
comedy special my first ever my debut
comedy special is coming out it's
available for pre-order I know it's on
iTunes so if you click the link in my
bio or you just search disgraced Queen
on iTunes it'll show up I would really
appreciate the pre-order I just
appreciate all the support like you
could love it you can hate it I don't
care just like buy it you know and I'm
really excited about it like honestly
like me announce so early on I just
can't even fathom like that it's coming
up I know that I know it's been hard for
you to like have an announcement and
then not something like tangible but
growth so painful Jackie you have no
idea what it's like I can't just want
people to watch it I know but like it'll
be here soon enough
honestly time is just flying by it's
absolutely insane that we're in the
middle of June July is a pond us and not
got much to show for it yeah like
remember when this whole thing started
and we were like bye my birthday my
birthday is July 10th we're like we'll
be out of this and now it's like very
possible I'm going to have a semi
quarantine birthday it will get out for
your birthday but if we don't we will be
like doing G and I'm making pop right in
my kitchen
it's kill me like just kill me and yeah
what like so many birthdays have like
flew by in quarantine it was like your
husband and my husband but it's like
husbands it's like birthdays don't
aren't like that important for boys but
like you know like for me it's like I
know that technically me and Ben both
are gonna have birthdays like in the
same maybe quarantine but like for me it
seems like such a bigger deal maybe I'm
just like so self-obsessed but I just
feel like old man old men like your
birthday's aren't as important yeah I
also think like you just have a better
track record of having up throwing a fun
birthday party for yourself and like me
above everyone else versus been like
he's had some stinkers some doozies yeah
no I mean I do love a theme and I had so
many good ideas
I was actually for this birthday that
never ended up happening I was gonna
revamp um a party that I did a few years
ago which was fabulous it was the
hoedown theme but I didn't really like
um build out the theme that much it was
just like I was limited in my budget and
everyone just like showed up in costumes
and I had like I had ordered like 10
bales of hay from like a farm upstate
and they were like so confused why they
were delivering to a bar in New York but
they did it and that was like the extent
of my decor and it was really planning
I'm like having a more elevated one this
year was like a country cover band and
like true decorations um but I never I
never got to it so I guess it'll have to
be good oh wait at home 26 we thought
about that
that is so old yeah I guess it'll be
lucky 27 yeah um okay well that's cool
that'll be fun this weekend aside from
being hungover I continued to watch Real
Housewives of Potomac I'm in the middle
of season three I've met Candice and
like Karen huger you know owes millions
to the government and I'm just like so
shook at the fact that like eat the
words grand Tom continue to be
associated with her name and she is the
most delusional housewife of all time
it's literally and you know it and
that's like a big accomplishment because
the house mice aren't delusional it's
infuriating no it's like she makes Sonja
Morgan look like no time has got it
together know it that's what I was
saying but maybe you didn't understand
like a few Weeke like maybe last week
when we were talking about it like she
infuriates me and like I love that she's
so hilarious but like she holds everyone
to like the craziest standard of
accountability when it's like her whole
time on the show has been a force I
don't know but then when I think about
it it's like she actually doesn't really
come for anyone about their stuff like
she like whenever like Pete like Ashley
as always she's the [ __ ] queen of
accountability and Carrie never really
brings up people's dirty laundry
probably cuz she has so much no I meant
like accountability like in society like
you have to act a certain way be a
certain way that she's the grand dom and
it's that was just you're really
the first season though she was like
that backseat also the scene where they
go to Nemacolin which we obviously have
to go there because it looks so like
Farm Germany and actually steals her wig
and puts it on Kern but there that was
the craziest scene I was on the floor
she really looked like her what do you
think of Candice because I actually
really liked her and a lot of people
don't like I'm alone in liking her so I
know that like and I'm confused cuz
right now I do like her I do um but I
don't love her like I feel as though I
should considering like she's Miss
America like she's so cute and I'm
starting to think like so I don't
understand how she is on this show and
not her mom who pays for everything like
it makes total is and she's really so
young I don't know how old she is but
she seems even younger than Monique and
she does it like her husband her mom
pays for her house with her husband like
I feel like we're watching this woman's
story line of oh I'm still paying for my
kids like why I like her her mom is like
is very affluent and successful like why
isn't she the one on this show like
Candice really feels like a touch too
young they do that a lot on Housewives
because for the most part like the
people who watch Bravo specifically
Housewives it's a lot it's an older
demographic like we were just talking
over the weekend I said tomorrow I'm
like have you ever watched an episode of
Real Housewives like ever and she said
she's never seen one minute like the
young kids don't watch it and eventually
like it's gonna age out so they always
throw in like a Lea like someone younger
to like bring the audience demographic
potentially down and that's what I feel
like they did with Candice and Monique
but I agree like I hate 8/8 when people
like their whole storyline is like money
from their parents like it's just so
boring like I like people who have
financial freedom yeah okay I just
looked her up she's actually not not
young she just I guess seems really
young oh how old is she she's 33 now so
when I'm watching this she's probably
like 31 or 30
that's perfect like there was um Kim
Zolciak was on Real Housewives of
Atlanta like nobody realized because she
like wear so much makeup but she's act
she was actually like in her young 30s
when she started yeah you know who's
super young Ashlee like Ashlee but she
has
her husband she's Layton's more mature
yeah and she is and she is really mature
um so I don't know I'm just not sold on
Candice yet and yeah it's just but like
I know that there's nothing I don't
dislike her at all I'm just like what I
met Monique I was like this but Monique
is one of my favorite housewives of all
time like she just has she's just firing
and all cylinders she has it all oh my
god so funny Jackie and I we were on
FaceTime like Jackie was calling me
about some Potomac stuff and so many of
the husband's are involved in sports and
it's hard to know like you can be in
sports and like literally make 200
million dollars or you can be like a
benchwarmer and you can make like five
hundred grand so it's like there's no it
just me sometimes but you just say that
you work in sports and it's very
ambiguous so then he's like really into
sports we were like rattling off names
like who have you heard of like who do
you think is where like her then yeah
like would it make sense for Eddie
Jordan's wife to like get divorced from
him and still live in the nicest house
of all the women in Potomac and he said
he's possible probably like Ben knew
like his coaching career and he then
said that he's probably like super super
rich then we asked if he knew Juan Dixon
and he said he never heard of him and
Ben is like a huge from the time like
it's not like maybe he played before
Ben's time like Ben was at every Knicks
game like when he was nine like he is
obsessed so like if he doesn't know what
someone in the NBA like they weren't
good yeah so he didn't know antics in
and he said Chris Samuels sounded very
very familiar but then only like
recently got really really into football
so got it well a so I did the same thing
with Zach I asked him I was like you
know why Jordan AC yeah me a coach I
said you know who Juan Dixon is he's
like I watch Real Housewives of Potomac
oh my god it's so funny so funny I was
like okay well he watched season one so
I was like do you know Chris Samuels and
he was like yes but he didn't know him
from Potomac but he knows him from the
field so it's a little that is my
favorite thing to do like if I'm in a
room with like men and they're talking
about sports like can you believe how
many touchdowns Kroy Biermann scored
last week like I'm always just trying to
see if no yeah I'm always trying to see
if like the housewife husbands who play
sports like or that good because on the
show they of course their wives are
always hyping them up but you know what
happens on the field is the truth you
know so I
like I'm I was creamier than any good
and Kroy Biermann um he like had a sad
end of his career but for a while at
Atlanta he was like poppin yes yeah um
can you just talk for five minutes my
air on the minute I'm sorry seconds just
yeah I could talk for I could talk for
15 seconds about my love of Real
Housewives of Potomac if you haven't
watched yet it's all on Hulu I've gotten
a lot of messages asking where I'm
watching all the seasons they're all
free to stream on Hulu so head over
there and sign on get entertained it's
so good it's really so good I I'm really
excited to catch up because I avoided
all spoilers except I know that Monique
has maybe at some point um so I just
want to know like where everyone's out I
won't even look at them on Instagram
because I don't want to know like who
has a new last name like you know that's
the hardest part um watching something
late it's not being able to look at the
people's instagrams like oh that is my
cross where anytime I finish a show I
like roll over go on my Instagram and
like see what the people are up to it's
always like a little anticlimactic I
don't think a lot of the spoilers but
Omegas great because the spoilers don't
have a lot to do with like the
relationships like the marriages okay
the crazy or [ __ ] happens
interesting well I look forward to
finishing it um hopefully yeah so
there's four seasons done and then the
new season premiere soon right yeah
they're pushing it back obviously
because of uh yeah Kovach any hope that
they're filming during this time because
I feel like they'll have really
interesting insight into you know George
Floyd and the black lives matter
movement I'm just curious to hear what
they say since they're all like super
smart yeah well things are getting back
to filming I was on um now like my
Instagram is sort it's like becoming
like there's paparazzi photos like
people I saw like John Legend was on set
for a music video this weekend like la
opened up like filming on Friday so I
think things are gonna start to to
return one can only help us yes so um
we're gonna do a fabulous show I have a
little bit to share in the TV recap
segment
I watched the king of Staten Island and
I have so many thoughts like it
like there's not enough time for my
thoughts um and since it's Monday we are
now going to assign our twist movie of
the week that we're gonna recap on
Friday and so many people recommended
this movie and we never turn down an
opportunity to watch Michael B Jordan so
we are gonna watch just mercy which they
have made free on a bunch of streaming
services for the month of June so it
should be super easy for you guys to
find it came like it was probably the
most recommended one that we got um and
I have no idea what it's about like I'm
just gonna watch it and love doing that
and I'm so excited so we'll recap it on
Friday if you have time this week make
sure to find two hours to watch it I've
heard it's fabulous
yeah me too I'm excited so so I think
now it's time for the Fast Five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and that's true Jackie but allow me just
a moment to express myself because I
this sinking feeling you know like I
would like a feeling of like remission
like um like devastation and it's like
an element of like heartbroken s I'm not
gonna lie and that's me dramatic yeah
and it's coming from the fact that I
haven't been able to tell everyone it's
like major secret that today's episode
is brought to you by liquid I be an easy
healthy solution for dehydration one
sticky liquid I be in 16 ounces of water
hydrates you faster and more efficiently
than water alone each serving provides
as much hydration as two to three
bottles of water plus vitamin C b3 b5 b6
and b12 proper hydration is crucial for
your immune system and can boost your
immunity more vitamin C than an orange
and has as much potassium as a banana
what we love most about liquid IV is
that they're on a mission to change the
world
they're donating 2.3 million servings in
response to Coba 19a products are being
donated to hospitals first responders
food banks veterans and active military
believe it or not dehydration occurs in
three out of four people which leads to
daily headaches dizziness brain fog
muscle fatigue muscle cramps dry skin
and more to stay hydrated with water
alone you'd have to drink eight full
eight ounce glasses of water a day but
thankfully there's like would I be the
fastest most efficient way to stay
hydrated what makes it so effective is
the CTT cellular transport technology
the optimal ratio of glucose sodium and
potassium delivers water and nutrients
into the bloodstream it's a perfect
balance to help you hydrate more quick
and effectively than water alone one
stick could have liquid I be in a 16
ounce of water can give you as much
hydration as two or three bottles of
plain water liquid IV is available
nationwide at Target
Whole Foods in Costco or you can get 25
percent off when you go to liquid I be
calm and use the code toast to check out
that's 25% off anything you order when
you use promo code toast at liquid I be
calm get better hydration today at
liquid I be calm promo code TOA st you
can also find them they should Mart at
Target Whole Foods or Costco alright get
hydrated let's die breathing we have
some we have some stories for you today
first story big story Vanderpump whirls
alum Stassi Schroeder is pregnant
expecting her first child was fiance oh
Clark
Stassi Shorter's life goes on with her
without the inner pump rules the Bravo
alum is pregnant and expecting her first
child with her fiance beau Clark Us
Weekly can exclusively reveal sassy
covered her baby bump with a long
cardigan while picking up food with beau
in LA on Friday June 12th the news of
the reality stars pregnancy comes four
days after she was fired from Vanderpump
rules following eight seasons on the
show my jaw like hit the floor like
first of all what a crazy time to like
just have happen to have gotten pregnant
you know and I just I can't like there I
just have so many questions here like I
don't even know where to start like
first of all have they actually
confirmed it no this is Us Weekly
reporting it but I do feel like Us
Weekly is right for some reason I just
don't feel like that people have like
fake pregnancy rumors flying around in
the middle of a firing like this yeah
exactly so ya know I was shocked um
definitely a plot twist but I'm really
happy for her and obviously there's a
lot going on in her career right now but
like major personal milestones like this
he just puts things into perspective
about like what's important in life and
I'm glad that she has some joy at this
time yeah like I know that a lot of
people don't necessarily feel bad for
her and regardless of you know what she
did to get herself in this position like
when the whole world like hates you and
turns its back on you like
it's it's devastating like we have been
there and even though like we had things
that we have to be held accountable for
like you can't even describe to a person
like what that feeling is like you feel
so isolated so alone so depressed and so
the fact that like Stassi has something
to look forward to and it's like a
really really big deal like that like
just saved her entire like mental health
like it's it's like it's fabulous
honestly yeah it's it's really good
happiness it kind of reminds me of like
how I got engaged like the same day we
got cancelled and like it just kind of
put life into perspective for a minute
where it's like this is what's important
like love and and family and I'll be
okay yeah I just like cannot get over
the timing like it's so crazy it's so
crazy and just like got pregnant or in
quarantine like another baby you like
this is when we're about to start to
hear about them yeah and I'm curious um
like how far along she is because a lot
of people were citing her podcasts from
quarantine where she was talking about
like her and beau trying truths for the
first time and like drinking so she has
to be pretty early yeah I wonder I mean
I'm just gonna assume that it's true
because I can't imagine this would be
fake news you know so I'm gonna operate
under the guise that it's true
Us Weekly reported it and normally I
wouldn't like wholeheartedly trust US
weekly but then like every other news
outlet Daily Mail be online like they
reported it as fact based on Us Weekly
so this is either how rumors get started
or just have the news works I'm not sure
and I don't know if she'll confirm it
until when you see like a huge bump
because she's not really speaking out
right now yeah but she did step out did
you see the pictures yeah I mean she
obviously like hired some sort of crisis
PR because things have turned around
quite a bit in the last week she was
seeing paparazzi like those obviously
staged that always happens it's fine um
she has this pregnancy announcement
there been like a few articles um just
like about how devastated she is so
she's obviously now trying to get back
out there or at least start the process
because her and Kristen have definitely
hired some sort of um management yeah
well regardless I'm happy for her happy
news happy news are you ready for some
other happy news and you know what a
cancellation like this obviously is when
you're going through it horrible
but you learn so much about yourself
about life about the world and honestly
like it's terrible when you're going
through it but like I at least feel like
we became such better people because of
it like as much as I wish that didn't
happen I'm actually grateful in a lot of
ways that it did because it totally to
me as a person like in a matter of
months I became so much more like
sensitive and empathetic and just it
really changed me and honestly that's a
great kind of growth to go through
before becoming a mom 1,000% I couldn't
agree more
so I'm a sure to see it that way right
now probably no it's hard to but I think
eventually that she will I do think so
yeah
um Outer Banks is chase Stokes confirms
he's dating his co-star Madeline Kline
chase jokes and Madame Klein played
popular couple John B and Sarah Cameron
on the Netflix series OBX so John D and
Sarah Cameron are dating in real life if
you watch over the exes news is
everything of the sort he confirmed the
romance with her on social media he
shared photos from the couple's beach
shade on Instagram along with the
caption cats out of the bag then she
wrote in the comments section of his
post saying topper punching the air
right now and I've fallen and I can't
get up oh my that's so cute can I just
say that I posted this on our Instagram
to like update our followers and I
thought everyone in the world like
watched OBX so many of our listeners and
followers were like who are these people
I kind of like thought that was gonna
happen cuz even when I saw the picture
the first time like it's not like the
most obvious thing ever
um and then again not everyone did watch
OBX a lot of people don't understand
still don't know like what we're talking
about it's the show that came out on
Netflix while we were in quarantine it's
really good it's kind of gives me like
last song vibes oh it gives you me like
national treasure vibes but it also
gives me where the crawdads sing vibes
and the two main characters who are in a
relationship in the show are now dating
in real life and honestly at the time
where we just lost Lilly and Cole this
was exactly what we needed and we are
getting a second season of OBX and as
we've said here many many times on the
show like if our main characters are
truly in love and they're dating in real
life and on the show like it elevates
the
chemistry it elevates it elevates every
element of the show so I'm not only
looking forward to season 2 you OBX just
cuz like it's a good show but also
because I I know that their love is real
now like when they're in the Bahamas
yeah yeah that's true I'm excited to see
knowing that their love is real because
I definitely felt like their friendship
was real before but it's an atomic ass
so anybody could really be mixed up with
someone else
yeah and honestly like if I just
happened to find myself on the OBX cast
like I would definitely be trying to
date JJ like I think he's so cute I know
everyone like dies for John Bay but he
is just like not my cup of tea
what Oh between Jambi and JJ I like JJ's
not for me I definitely thought John B
was cuter when the show started I
thought that like JJ and John B should
have been switched characters like to me
JJ was like the obvious star but I guess
like to nobody else no not to me not to
me
JJ was like perfect for date I mean
don't get me wrong I would go on a date
with either of them I'm just looking at
things through a critical eye ya know
they're they're all very handsome it's a
very handsome handsome crew ya know it's
a great show like I actually um really
enjoyed myself while watching it which
is a feeling it's fleeting and
Quarantine like things just don't give
me joy anymore you know he's really
pathetic so I missed that like week
where I watched OBX and Ben was really
into a tunas like we got to do something
it's date night yeah so sweet okay you
ready for a next story is it um is it
the story that's brought to you by noon
yes really tragic this third story is
brought to you by new getting in shape
doesn't have to be about losing a
specific amount of weight or a magic
number on the scale it's about building
healthier habits and feeling better
about yourself if fitting into your
favorite pair of jeans is your goal
great but there are many reasons you
might want to practice self-care and
every person is different
new is the habit changing solution that
helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses it's based in
psychology so numa's gonna teach you why
you do the things you do and it empowers
you with the tools you need to break
habits and replace them with better ones
numa's not a diet it is it easy and
healthy and easy to stick to way of life
on noon no food is considered a good
batter off-limits they just teach you
moderation and it can be used in
conjunction with many pre-existing diets
if you want noon doesn't tell you what
not to do sorry noonim doesn't tell you
what to do and what not to do it teaches
you how to look inside your own mind
they make better decisions for yourself
I feel like you can apply this like all
elements under your life but healthy in
particular like once you realize like
patterns and like it's not always just
like the physical act of eating it's
like a lot of the like mental structure
it's like why do I do X and and just
Noom like totally tackles it from a
psychological perspective which is super
interesting ah one of the biggest and
most accurate food databases available
that lets you track meal habits
visualize portion sizes and see calorie
density at a glance we are all strapped
for time so noone just asks you to
commit to 10 minutes a day for yourself
if you go off track there's no shaming
just hit tips to help you get back on
track you don't have to change it on one
day small steps make big progress sign
up for your trial today at noon n oo m
dot-com slash toast what do you have to
lose
visit new maqams size toast to start
your trial today that's n oo m comm
slash toast sign and feel great
ok next story really sweet news from
Barbra Streisand who is gifting George
Floyd's daughter with Disney stock
George Hyde's
six-year-old daughter is Disney's newest
stockholder thanks to a generous gift
from singer Barbra Streisand Gianna
Floyd thanks tries in on her Instagram
account on Saturday and posted a series
of photos displaying the Disney letter
and certificate she received in the mail
from the 10 time Grammy Grammy Award
winner quote thank you at Barbra
Streisand for my package I am now a
Disney stock holder thanks to you she
wrote alongside a photo of her smiling
with the certificate she tries n also
gave John two copies of her studio
albums my name is Barbara and Color Me
Barbara from 1965 and 1966 respect
little shameless self-promotion love to
see it this is such a generous gift and
so sweet and good on Barbra Streisand
yes stock is such like a fabulous gift
because like I like it obviously
increases and decreases in value
but it's like a very um like long-term
like sturdy gift do you know what I mean
yes especially Disney stock I feel as
though we'll go the distance
you're always yeah wanting stock for
your birthday and everyone's like no
one's like what do you want for your
birthday like whatever you would spend
on a gift like just give me in stock and
everyone literally like laughs in my
face I just don't like it
actually no logistical ëhow I guess cuz
I could do that like I'm gonna start
looking for a birthday gift for you soon
like maybe I'll just get stock instead
but like how do i buy stocks and give
them to you can you go to the stock
store your let me say hi no I'm kidding
are you playing like uh you go to stock
at ease
you go to stock at X is where they sell
shoes you go to summits and buy shoes
and you give them to your sister for her
birthday you take the subway to the New
York Stock Exchange and you stand on the
platform you're like hey I would like to
exchange some stocks and they're like
you want to exchange your socks no my
stocks and I think that's how it goes
okay so I'm not getting any stocks for
your birthday if that's what it takes a
big it requires human interaction I'm
out I feel that I definitely think all
jokes aside you could buy some stocks
online I just know we're gonna get this
ticket yeah well like where do you print
them maybe you make a little thing on
Etsy oh for sure you buy sacks in
someone's name and then you make just
like a card on Etsy that's like you are
the new stock holder right because I
actually um play around a lot on Robin
Hood and I have flicks and say star this
is not an ad but since they started
sponsoring our show like I've used it
because TBG like and everything TV GT
says like I just do I'm he recommended
it as like a great way to like invest in
small amounts and they don't send me
certificates when I buy stock right and
then how do you buy socking just put it
like give them to someone else
Robin Hood is like just one to one you
can't include anyone else right so
Barbra Streisand figured it out and she
bought it for Gianna and it's back to
that yeah it's super super sweet a
really thoughtful gift and I just feel
like in a lot of ways I know that it
feels like the country is like so
divided and there's like lots of turmoil
but I feel like in a lot of ways this
tragedy is also bringing out the good in
like it's hard to look at it through
that lens but I feel like for our own
sanity is like we have to look at it
through that lens and this is really
sweet so many people stepping up like we
reported Kanye last week and everyone's
just like wanting to help the families
and I just think it's great like of
course I wish that it didn't have to
happen but um it did happen and I think
it's really cool that a lot of people
are stepping up to like be there and
offer services pay legal fees it's it's
wonderful yes I agree well this next
story is exciting because we're kind of
getting back to our usual storytelling
because Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott
were spotted leaving in LA hot spot
after a night out and like just to see a
celebrity in a paparazzi photo holding
up their jacket like you don't know what
that does for my soul right now after
months of being deprived of that Kylie
Jenner and Travis Scott both enjoyed an
evening out Saturday in LA the parents
two two-year-old daughter stormy were
photographed leading the night sky
separately with Jenner's shielding her
face from the paparazzi as she walked
out of the hot spot in black heels and a
black jacket Travis Scott who was
dressed in the box he shirt and black
pants was spotted hopping into an
awaiting car covering his face with a
bottle
so also like are they together again I
just I do think they're friends and
they're and they're good Co parents and
also they just like wanted to have a
night out because they can and they
should and they would ya know I have so
many questions about this incident like
one restaurants in LA are open yes
that's what I'm seeing like I'm seeing
pop like people going like to catch LA
it just opened according to just Jared
and I'm like I'm so I'm so happy for LA
know that I am um I'm just like so
jealous and then in terms of Kylie and
Travis I feel like there's been so many
conflicting rumors for like the last two
years like since stormy was born about
are they together
are they not together and we never
really get confirmation like because
Kylie's not on Kardashians and that's
usually where they clear up rumors um
but she's not really on it and she
doesn't put her personal life out there
so we never really know so it's my
understanding that like they actually
haven't been together in a while but
they're really good friends maybe they
like you know kiss every now and then
like why not a lonely night but I just
think that like they like being spotted
together they like being co-parents they
love stormy you know they are their
family
exactly it's like her going out to
dinner with Scott Disick yeah it's like
he's a member of her family and vice
versa and they're just there for each
other whether they're romantically
entangled or not was anyone else around
like was Stas there was it truly just
the two of them I feel like that'll add
some context Paige takes only has photos
of the two of them getting into the cars
and you know what like it's been a dry
season for the Kardashians they need
some you know some tabloid drama so if
people are questioning like are Kylie
and Travis together that's like harmless
gossip
yeah and I think we'll be asking
ourselves that question lies we'll be
asking our children that question like
for a long time to come
I hope to be asking my children that
question and they're gonna be like mom
what the [ __ ] are you talking about yeah
it's super cute okay
fifth and final story an amazing story
nick nickelodeon pride tweet hints that
spongebob squarepants is gay
yes I love this this is so fabulous of
Pride Month tweet from the official
Nickelodeon Twitter account has the
internet believing SpongeBob SquarePants
is not just a happy guy quote
celebrating pride with the lgbtq+
community and their allies this month
and every month the kids network tweeted
out Saturday afternoon along with
rainbow embossed art of the beloved sea
sponge along with Korra from The Legend
of Korra who's bisexual and the
transgender actor Michael D Cohen from
Henry danger fans of the nautical
cartoon which began airing in 1999 have
long suspected sponge drive to be gay in
one 2002 episode called rock-a-bye by
valve spongebob and his best friend
Patrick parent and abandoned scallop
like a married couple
the internet quickly embraced the newly
out character okay I have so many
thoughts first of all happy Pride Month
to all our lgbtq+ toasters the toast
believes love is love we see it we hope
you have a great Pride Month I'm so
sorry that pride is canceled because it
is the best weekend of the year it's not
canceled in our hearts it's not camps no
hearts it's not um when we were kids
like people used to say it as a joke
like SpongeBob's gay
but you know what I feel like them
actually like confirming he's a gay
character like I just can't imagine like
what that does for like a kid watching
Spongebob who like no said he's gay and
he's just like used to seeing like only
like straight kids on TV and all of his
TV shows like it's all buried like
generically heterosexual I'm like I just
can imagine like what that does hurt
kids self-esteem to know that like
spongebob who's like even in my day was
like iconic like he's an eye everything
everything of the sort to know that he's
gay like I just can't imagine what that
does for the self-esteem of like kids
who are gay yeah yeah it's fabulous I
think it's so fabulous I I love that
they're sharing this with us like this
is this is beautiful and it was just
it's beautiful and it was just like a
really like classy announcement you know
yes like definitely so tasteful Sponge
Bob approved so I cannot believe Sponge
Bob still on the air let me just say
that I know well spongebob will live on
forever in the memes like the spongebob
means kill me they kill me
they kill me they're a plague there's a
spongebob mean for every emotion in the
book so true Jack so true so it's just I
love it fabulous that is my simple
request all things can be that's bigger
and better missed something inspiring to
help me get along I need a little
fabulous is that so wrong that was good
very very on pitch Thank You Claudia I
put my heart into it once you guys see
my comedy special you're gonna
understand all my jokes the pre-order on
iTunes you could click the link in my
bio on Instagram disgrace Queen is the
name of my special type it into iTunes
and pre-order
[Music]
it was that rectum panel that was our
fifth and final just like a little happy
pride news and I just feel like that's
what we all really needed
I know it's honestly like COBIT is just
disgraceful and taking pride away which
is just so much fun like I've been to
pride in LA in New York and it's just
like it's the best and I just can't
believe like we're not gonna have that
people aren't really gonna like go crazy
because it's not writing like where is
pride it's not right committed
Cobin is disgraceful covetous
disgraceful like I said it I said what I
said she said what she said I'm speaking
of pride really quickly I made an
amazing call to you and you agreed with
me and I just want to again put it on
this platform just in case like anyone
copies it and then it's like I would say
here saying it first rain on me by Lady
Gaga ariana grande is fabulous fabulous
fabulous fabulous and Lady Gaga has been
very vocal about her her love for drag
race she's been on multiple times on
even one time when they were introducing
all the contestants for the first
episode she walked in pretending to be a
drag queen and for a second everyone
thought she was a drag queen and they
realized it was Lady gaga and I just get
like her music specifically rain on me
is very heavily influenced by RuPaul
um because repose released music for
years and it's all very um it's like its
own genre of like gay pop and he really
utilizes like the the the God voice you
know it's like rain on me and that's
like his thing and I just I think it's
fabulous that Lady Gaga was inspired by
him and I don't feel like enough people
are making that connection so I just
want to say like rain on me sounds a lot
like RuPaul it's not on I found that to
be spot-on and Jackie never likes my
calls so that's how you know it's a
decent call I think it's a great call
and I'm I'm I'm unbiased when it comes
to your calls I just you know you do I
you don't like you think they're good
because you like me or think they're bad
because you hate me like you just see
them for what they are I think the call
I call the calls as they come in I call
it as I see it I call it as I see it
okay well my stories um let me give you
a little more context okay
you called me a [ __ ] call it as I see
it mmm didn't help Katie Maloney and
Lala better yep yeah okay TV TV recap
segment coming at you brought to you by
legacy box tons of DMS asking me about
this morning another read and so I got
it for you because it's a fabulous gift
for Father's Day
okay so legacy box is a super simple
mailing service to have all your
videotapes old camcorder tapes film
reels pictures digitally preserved onto
a thumb drive DVD or in the cloud so if
you have your favorite memories with
your dad you took a trip you had a
moment and all of those photos you can't
get like those videos off your camcorder
you put it in a box you send it to
legacy box they digitally preserve it
for you you can get it in a thumb drive
in the DVD you can get it on the cloud
and it's a fabulous gift for Father's
Day I feel like dads we're like so
sentimental like will love this so we're
here reminding you that Father's Day is
fast approaching and if you don't know
what you're getting for your dad and
they have boxes or bins of old home
videos and photos and storage you can
ensure that your family's legacy is
digitally preserved so it can be passed
down just in a matter of weeks it's
fabulous they help bring new life to
your old media by unlocking trapped
family memories and putting them in a
modern digital format that's easy to use
it's the best way for you to easily and
affordably digitally preserve your past
the start the process will start to
finish is so easy you pack and send it
their team digitizes everything by hand
and then you enjoy you get that
perfectly preserved digital copies I'm a
sub scribe gbg or the cloud ready to
watch share and enjoy plus they keep you
up to date with regular email updates
throughout the digitizing process
they're the world's largest digitizer of
home movies and photos and they have
helped over seven hundred and fifty
thousand families digitally preserve
their past
you can rediscover your glory days by
digitizing these irreplaceable heirlooms
with legacy box when the favorite kid
award this Father's Day give dad a
present he'll never forget and if you
want to get it for Dad maybe a fabulous
offer for you so check it out
get started preserving your family's
legacy today go to legacy box comm slash
toast to get an incredible 50 percent
off your first order
buy today they take advantage of this
exclusive offer and scented when you're
ready
legacy box is great for you or for
someone you love go to legacy box calm
flash
toast and say 50% while supplies last
love it
sign-on okay get your memories right so
oh really again I had planned to and I
it's weird that I like make a plan and
that I actually do it me and then wanted
to watch a king of Staten Island and we
purchased it because it was supposed to
be in theaters and it was $20 and I was
like damn that's a la that's maybe the
most I've ever spent on a rental but you
know what I'm wanting to support the
industry and I was okay and that's two
movie theater tickets you know it's if
you have hitters yeah exactly so it's
actually not but I just think if I was
in a theater and like if a movie is like
in the theater but like you have popcorn
and like the vibe it doesn't bother me
as much but like in my own bed like
don't waste my time a hundred percent I
hate to say it because like I really
champion Pete Davidson like I want him
to be successful but like this movie was
not good and I just I hate to be so
negative
especially like this is a debut movie
was supposed to be like kind of um
reflective of his life it was really I
think supposed to be it was done by Judd
Apatow and I think it was supposed to be
like what trainwreck was for Amy Schumer
like a burgeoning comedian um a funny
movie that's kind of similar to her life
in New York and it was just bad but
there were some interesting things I
thought and I'm like my jaw hit the
floor because Carly Aquilino was in it
who is a fabulous comedian from girl
code and she used to date Pete Davidson
before he was cool like she had him cool
yeah Wow and she was just like one of
his friends she wasn't like a huge part
of it but I just thought it was
interesting that they were working
together Pete obviously he wrote the
movie with Judd Apatow so like he had a
say in casting oh my god I still kind of
[ __ ] if they ever want him working out
me too
I actually really ship um Carly Aquilino
with the comedian from guy code Krista
says oh I know they have been together
in a while but I actually like really
shipped them together yeah they were
cute too okay I haven't seen the movie I
haven't decided yet if I'm gonna watch
it um let me tell you spoiler alert it
was should I marry long no you're not
gonna watch it just listen to me it was
very long and first of all I was in 30
minutes before I realized that his mom
who's a main character is Marisa Tomei
perfect whose iconic from my cousin
Vinnie um I just I couldn't really
decide what was wrong with the movie it
had no plot and then at the end like you
never found out what happened like he
was just like this kind of like oh um
don't spoil it just in case like I
probably at some point okay there was an
appreciation Vegas me no no there are
Walt's whele there was no resolution at
the end like there was a very small plot
like I don't even know if you could call
it a plot like I don't know if I could
tell you what the movie was about but
then at the end like there was like this
one conundrum like is he gonna do this
or this and you never found out first of
all second of all it was just so
frustrating to watch someone make poor
decisions you know like that is just my
least favorite thing and honestly my
least favorite character in the whole
movie was Pete like he was just so
annoying but now let me get to the
positives because first of all the movie
was definitely like an homage and a a
tribute to firefighters specifically his
dad like Pete's character's name was
Scott and Scott is the name of Pete's
dad so and there was like a whole
firefighter like story line and I feel
like the movie did a fabulous job of
just like respecting the hell out of
firefighters like they are truly like
heroes and like honestly not enough
people talked about it so for that I'm
grateful the movie was made because it
is in homage and it is an ode to
firefighters and like the whole
firefighting industry left that and like
they they dedicated it at the end to his
dad and like that gave me chills like I
loved and honestly I feel like the movie
in a lot of ways tackled how Pete feels
about his dad's death cuz he's always
joking about it but obviously like
everyone has real feelings but you never
hear that and I think this movie was
supposed to be like a more inward look
I'm like what he actually goes through
in dealing with his father's death and I
thought that was really profound and I
was really interesting to like know more
about him but man it was a long movie
like just to find that out um was it
better or worse than big-time
adolescence oh I'm so glad you asked it
was the same movie
yeah I felt like I feel like I've seen
this movie oh and and Machine Gun Kelly
was in it it was so similar I'm like why
are we making the same movie twice that
was like and they made you Cinderella's
at the same time nobody we're both
starring Lily Collins yeah that's true
you know actually it was so similar like
there was even a little kid element like
they were the same movie oh my god yeah
I was thinking I'm like they just took
place in different towns was the other
one not in Staten Island no it was
giving you like more like suburban
Westchester vibes I'm not sure never
been I think it was satin island that
would be crazy because the movies were
so similar and I was thinking that I'm
like haven't I just seen this movie and
then one like a little kid character
showed up I'm like alright now this is a
joke yeah that's so funny
okay cool you haven't persuaded me one
way or the other really so that's if you
love Pete Davidson like you will like
the movie because first of all it's all
about him second of all like you you get
to know like a deeper side of him that
you never get to see like on SNL or in
his stand-up cuz he's always like making
jokes but there's a person behind the
jokes and he's obviously like he has a
lot of pain and I think it was cool for
him to like be so vulnerable but if I'm
looking this like like a movie critic
like the movie was bad okay
Thank You sandy Kenyon I said what I
said and I'm sandy Kenyon with the
Eyewitness News movie menifee minute
come on we've got to get sandy Kenyon on
this show he's an New York icon yeah we
did we'll work on that that's a good
goal at a cheerless no guests that we
want oh that's good okay so anything
else did you watch anything the only
other thing that I watched was was song
land with Ben Platt and I just want to
say that I'm pretty certain that it's
the best episode of song man yet all
four songs from the beginning I didn't
know how they were gonna choose two
three the choice that they made was
actually a really good choice then clap
made a good point and then the three
songs were incredible and the one that
they chose I didn't even think was the
best one and it's amazing so I think
like from a musical perspective it's the
best whole episode I still think that
the Old Dominion one where young came
out is the best song from song land I
also think there are some really good
ones but this vampire episode is like a
perfect if you
to explain to someone like what is song
in one episode like I would show them
that episode oh that's good you know if
you're trying to get like your husband
to watch hey there in Tibet clap like
what I need I don't know who isn't that
I also like don't know that many people
yeah but I also love about smugglin it's
said there's really an artist for
everyone like I don't necessarily watch
every single episode like even though I
love country like I did not watch the
Martina McBride one because I just don't
like I'm not a Stan and I'm I have
limited time actually that's not true
but you know what I mean like there's
episodes for everyone they do country
they do pop they do rock they do old
they do new so it's really we were
talking about this over the weekend it's
the perfect show it's the perfect show I
hope it lives on forever um and now that
I said that and I'm because the universe
miss and I love it like it's gonna be
cancelled um but it's fortunately
everything Jackie likes does get
cancelled so I song land no I think it
does really well I don't want to jinx it
any further
um okay I think that's all she wrote I
think that is all she wrote like she I
guess it's money so she's a little tired
too from the jump and she's just I
understand one yeah thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
millennium Morning Show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as podcasts
anywhere podcasts we found set Spotify
iTunes stitcher Public Radio I already
cast blocks all the places wherever you
listen to podcast by this one
interesting five star view about a
beautiful stunning and swear we are
purer my comedy special is available on
iTunes disgraced Queen and head over to
our patreon channel patreon.com/scishow
morning toast for extra content every
month videos audios all the stuff Ben
Zack Olivia all the stuff check it out
thank you for new morning new episode is
up now G and I in the queue making the
pizza drinking some wine listen to some
music it's good times it's good vibes
head over there now we'll see you
tomorrow bye